Donald Trump has suggested multiple times
that we should bomb hurricanes, bomb hurricanes
to stop them.
It sounds like a satirical news headline.
It sounds like a joke, but it's the suggestion
not of a random 73 year old guy that you just
saw urinating underneath the subway platform.
These are the words of a 73 year old guy who
happens to be president of the United States
and the White House is not denying it.
Here's a paraphrased quote.
This is the stuff of horrors.
I got it.
Why don't we nuke them?
Trump said they start forming off the coast
of Africa as they're moving across the Atlantic.
We drop a bomb inside the eye of the hurricane
and disrupted.
Why can't we do that per axios?
Who is reporting on this?
Asked how the briefer reacted to Trump's suggestion.
The source says that the briefer said to Trump,
sir, we'll look into that.
They're placating Trump.
This is how it works.
Behind the scenes.
Trump says, what about bombing or nuking hurricanes?
And they say, sir, we are going to take a
look into that.
Trump reiterated the suggestion that the government
can intervene with bombs against hurricanes
before they make landfall multiple times.
And listen, Trump seems to think he knows
a lot about nukes, right?
Remember this beauty.
Okay, having nuclear, my uncle was a great
professor and scientist and engineer, Dr.
John Trump at MIT.
Good.
Good genes.
Very good genes.
Okay.
Very smart.
The Wharton School of Finance, very good,
very smart.
You know, if you're a conservative Republican,
if I were a liberal, if like, okay, if I ran
as a Liberal Democrat, they would say I'm
one of the smartest people anywhere in the
world.
It's true, but when you're a conservative
Republican, they try, Oh, do they do a number?
That's why I always started with went to Wharton,
was a good student, went there, went there,
did this, built the four yet I have to give
by liquid dentals all the time because we're
at a little disadvantage.
But you look at the nuclear deal, the thing
that really bothers me, and it would have
been so easy and it's not as important as
these lives.
Our nuclear is so powerful.
My uncle explained that to me many, many years
ago, the power, and that was 35 years ago.
He would explain the power of what's going
to happen.
And he was right.
Who would've thought,
yeah, so that was all one sentence by the
way.
Uh, the briefer, in another case, when Donald
Trump suggested bombing hurricanes was reportedly
quote, knocked back on his heels and that
it became so quiet in the room that you could
hear a Gnat fart in the meeting.
According to a source that spoke to axios.
Trump has reportedly brought this idea up
multiple times with the Department of Homeland
Security, with national security officials
with a senior administration official asked
about this.
The White House is not denying it.
They said, we don't comment on private discussions
that the president may or may not have had
with his national security team.
That's an admission that this was suggested
by Trump.
Okay.
In the world of politics, if you are presented
with something completely ridiculous, that
of course didn't happen.
Like, Hey, we heard Donald Trump suggested
going out and personally murdering people
in the streets.
Like Trump wants to go out and shoot some
people.
Is that true?
Is that's something Trump said, you would
immediately have multiple officials saying
absolutely ridiculous.
The reporting is false.
Never said it.
Absolutely ridiculous.
They said something here that's almost as
crazy.
Why don't we bomb hurricanes?
And the White House is saying, we don't comment
on what the president did or didn't say, and
there's another administration official who's
actually defending the idea saying that quote
Donald Trump's goal is simply to keep catastrophic
hurricanes from hitting the mainland, which
is a good goal to have.
This is a defense of the idea of bombing hurricanes
that Donald Trump says has adjusted multiple
times.
So let's go through it.
Trump's not the only person to think of this
idea.
Okay.
Back during the Eisenhower era, it was considered
we knew a lot less at the time.
Is it possible that we could use these new
bombs that we made to disrupt hurricanes 70
years ago?
However long ago it was, a scientists agree
it just won't work.
Period.
The only disagreement that exists with this
story is the Trump suggestive bombing or did
Trump suggest nuking the hurricanes, so bombs,
non nuclear weapons versus nuclear weapons.
There are reports of both.
That's the only disagreement that really exists
here.
Now it's also kind of interesting that in
the background of this, once again, it's always
near non white people that Trump is thinking
of dropping the bombs, right?
Like I get, this is probably just a coincidence,
but Trump is thinking, let's bomb the hurricanes
where they form near Africa may be coincidental,
but just sort of notable nonetheless given
how this administration has been run.
If Trump were a family member or a friend,
if you cared about him, if Trump was a personal
contact, you would have staged an intervention
by now and you would have gotten the person
some help.
How did we elect someone this stupid or unhinged?
And then the answer is, well, because 60 million
people thought this was a good idea, and that
basically tells you everything you need to
know about the American electorate.
This is a crisis.
The crisis is Trump, but the crisis is also
that there are tens of millions of people
who are going to enthusiastically vote to
reelect the guy in November of 2020.
Ultimately, this is going to be a get out
the vote election.
Uh, and that relates to what I want to talk
about next.